by definition only the coward is capable
of the highest heroism for the coward
fights despite his weak nature prince al
ant the son of King allant travels to
the bow latarian palace under the name
Ostrava in order to hide his true
identity the scourge has devastated the
kingdom and as the player sets out to
kill the arch demons Ostrava fights
through the bullet Arion palace with the
sole intention to find his father and to
dispel the rumors that his father the
King has become a demon Ostrava is wise
but weak his lived a pampered life yet
he takes up the legendary weapons of a
hero and attempts to fight his way to
his Father's throne we first found a
Strava on a ledge with no way back he
was surrounded by dredge wings which
were waiting to cut him down that was a
bold jump a surprise indeed well now
that you are here pray thee fend off
these draggling 'he's
my thanks for your brave rescue i'm
Ostrava of boletaria we fought the
dredge wings off as a Strava watched we
can tell from the way he talks he almost
assumes it's our duty to rescue him this
will change as a Strava continues to
discover her hopeless ease in the world
around him much of his time is spent
within the Nexus like many others he has
trouble finding the courage to leave a
Strava like you is bound to the Nexus
die in human form and you'll resurrect
in an ethereal soul form demon souls
allow you to keep your sanity while
you're in this soul form and a mature
demon soul can restore your corporeal
human form but die in soul form and
that's the end
you'll lose both your sanity and your
life resurrecting as a black phantom
that's why death is such a fearsome
thing that's why Astra is afraid to
leave the Nexus but he came here for a
reason
at its peak boletaria was a grand
Kingdom the king his knights and his
subjects were modest and plain but also
steadfast and compassionate in the
distant southern kingdom boletaria was
known as paradise on earth but look at
what has become of us now I refuse to
believe that this is what father wished
for our great land Ostrava progresses
slowly but surely always in fear of
losing his life but driven to reach his
father's keep with your help what would
have been impossible becomes a
possibility over here it's me Ostrava
look at me I getting surrounded by evil
warriors could you perhaps help me one
last time clear out the soldiers at the
far end of this passage if it pleases
you
the Lord's path just down yonder has
degenerated into a feeding ground for
flying dragons have your wits about you
thank you that makes twice thanks to you
I can now forge ahead in boletaria they
speak of the two swords demon Brent and
soul Brent one banishes that witch a
Fowles man and the other banishes man
himself dropped into the world along
with the old one they seemed to
symbolize the battle between man and his
demons soul Brent the sword that grows
in power the more demonic the soul the
wields it is missing Ostrava is getting
closer and closer to his father could it
be that his father took up that sword
the sword that banishes man
help how solstar soldiers are after me
thank you for rescuing me you saved my
life this is the third time I am truly
indebted to you
I must go my father the King awaits me
just over there
the sad truth is that once King allant
was a benevolent ruler who cared greatly
for his subjects he fought diligently
against the vile and the depraved alas
as he aged he became melancholy allonge
began a search for a method to expand
his might his search brought him to the
nexus where knowledge of the soul arts
were bestowed upon him this was not
enough and eventually allowed to work
the old one which granted him
unfathomable power this power devastated
his human form transforming his body
into a pathetic mutated creature this is
not a lot this is a magnificent demon
that'll aren't fashioned a doppelganger
designed to lead the demon scourge and
reap more souls to quench the thirst of
the old one the real king resides within
the old one believing that the old one
is a gift of mercy from God in his old
age allowed to recognize that pain evil
and misery filled the world it was so
hopeless that the only way to fight
poison was with poison so olanta woke
the old one hoping for its deep fog to
engulf the land and absorb every last
Soul only then did he believe that human
suffering would end despite all odds
Ostrava finally fights his way into his
Father's throne room past the soldiers
who have had their souls stolen past the
fat officials who torture and maim bust
the Dragons defending the Kings keep and
up the final steps of his journey
tragically Prince alliant discovers that
his father has in fact become a demon
this is not quite the truth as the real
Lant resides within the old one but
either way it is true that a lot once a
benevolent ruler is indeed responsible
for the demon scourge that wiped out
humanity oh it's you is it my father is
up above well
what's left of him anyway he's
transformed into a fiendish demon I
began this quest in a search for truth
but it seems I was a fool to even try
please kill my father in his degenerated
state he can only bring peril to the
lands this key fits the boletaria
mausoleum inside the mausoleum are my
father's two swords soul Brandt and
demon brand use them to bring an end to
this madness overcome with despair and
before you can stop him as driver kills
himself in sole form
his black phantom appears shortly after
Ostrava found the truth but it didn't
bring him peace his quest was for
nothing
yours wasn't
on the first day man was granted basalt
and with a clarity for in that very
potential was seen yet
on the second day upon earth was planted
an irrevocable poison a soul devouring
demon for like the demon man had an
insatiable destructive appetite for
souls